the jurogan experience did you see that
story in california by the way about how
they're going to try and re-teach math
did you see this one from the new york
times what yeah it's all about they
teach math so they're going to figure
out how to teach math differently they
said that they don't want to have
they're getting rid of some of the
objective standards with regard to math
because math is and they want to get rid
of the idea that there are naturally
gifted children they said they're not
allowed to say that they're naturally
gifted children anymore
isn't that the case with uh new york as
well then they get yeah they're trying
to get rid of the magnet schools over
there too but gifted programs yes the
the the gifted programs because too many
asian kids
america's white supremacists all the
asians are succeeding i love that
narrative so no what are they trying to
do with math so it was this article in
the new york times and i'm trying to
remember all the details they said
you're not allowed to talk about
naturally gifted kids
you're not supposed to
reward right answers or punish wrong
answers
yeah so there's like a big kind of
parents revolt going on in california
over this cause the idea was that
there was too much racial disparity in
math performance in california and so
change changed the standards which by
the way i can't think of anything more
racist than that
that is so super racist it's like
not enough black kids are scoring well
on the test that means that black kids i
guess are too dumb to do well on these
tests get rid of the tests like
or alternatively there's an explanation
where kids need to study more well you
only find out if someone knows things if
you test them it's the only way you find
out
how else do you find out you have to
like say show me how to do this problem
and then the kid tries and you go oh
that's not how you do it by the way i
think this is like entire i think the
scam that is college is predicated on a
society trying to get around the basic
truth that you just said which is we can
tell by test scores whether you know
things and are good at things well i
mean obviously there's some tests that
favor people that have grown up in
certain environments because you have
more access to certain kinds of
information
but
once you teach people
and then you test them the only there's
only one way to find out
whether or not they know the information
they have to be tested so the idea that
you're going to eliminate tests and
somehow make things more equitable or
more even is kind of crazy actually what
you're going to do is you're going to
make people more racist is what you're
going to do and the reason for that is
because thomas soul talks about this he
talks about different types of
discrimination and he says there's group
discrimination where you base your
perception of an individual on the group
data that is available
and then there's like discrimination
discrimination which is you know that a
person is smart and they're a group you
don't like and so you just ignore the
fact they're smart because they're from
that group so the two examples that he
gives right is let's say that you're
walking down the street at night and
it's in an inner city neighborhood and
there's a black guy walking down the
street and he's wearing
a hoodie and he's a young guy 17 years
old
are you going to cross the street or not
if the opposing example is an 80 year
old white woman
right and he says well you know based on
the group statistics you're probably
going to cross the street more often if
it's the 17 year old black kid then it's
the 80 year old white woman
now let's say that that 17 year old
white kid that 17 year old black kid you
know you know the kid he's a nice kid if
you still cross the street that's what
makes you like a super giant racist in
the former case you're just using the
group data available the problem is that
using group data available very often is
wrong right what if the 17 year old kid
is a nice kid right you shouldn't be
doing that either you need specific data
test data is specific data so let's say
now that you are an administrator at a
college and you're not allowed to use
test data all you know is that on
average black kids score lower than
white kids
right so who do you let in
how do you make that decision wouldn't
it be better for black kids for you to
have the test data because you know
which black kids definitely deserve to
get in
as opposed to which ones don't deserve
to get in so you start using stupid
generalizations
the whole point is more specific data is
better more specific data fights
discrimination and yet we have this
whole weird idea that if we get rid of
specific data if we get rid of test data
objective data this is going to end
discrimination precisely the reverse
will occur people will start using
stupid stereotypes watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify